we jumped right into the rehearsals
which for me was basically Damien
knocking at my door with a drum set and
I told him I already had one but we it
was in pieces and had dust all over it
so he brought his shitty drum set we set
it up in my basement
[Music]
did I ask you to start playing again I
had lessons three days a week for about
four hours a day five six and
it was tough because even though I have
played drums since I was 15 and I've
played music my whole life I was so
scared to be messing up in front of all
these actual musicians so light
imitating art
[Music]
oh
Damian and I have these beautiful you
know iPhone videos of my first few
rehearsals now it's just like I can't do
it and uh slowly but surely kind of got
to a place where I felt really good
moving around the kit